a 13 year old 13 from California has
become the youngest graduate of a local
Community College friends and family
held a drive-by bash warjack Rico when
he graduated from Fulton College with
four associate's degree his mom said
Jack surpassed every single high school
standard by the time he was 11 he is now
headed to the University of Nevada Las
Vegas he's not sure of a career yet he
says he loves screenwriting Gail I don't
know if you saw Tony's post on Instagram
of him as a preteen on the way to his
67th viewing of Top Gun but when I was
13 I was reading comic books and was
still scared of girls so I salute jack
Vlad I'm so proud of you you've grown up
it's so nice but listen I think just a
little bit plan Tony to remember oh no
you grown up a lot I think we should all
make a plan Tony to remember Jack Rico
something tells me he's going to be a
household name sooner rather than later
look what he's done at 13 he's only
going up he's just getting started I
know yeah I think you're right although
he probably has a few additional things
to learn before he gets to adulthood
like how to shave how to cook eggs you
know life unfolds before him outside of
the classroom as well it's amazing to
think how young he really is 13 years
old hard to fathom I don't even want to
contemplate what I was doing at 13